[Música]
hablábamos nuevamente de economía en
directo américa de france24 daniela
blandón el gobierno de mexico prohíbe la
producción de cerveza en el norte del
país así es de raúl pues la indignación
ha crecido en las últimas semanas en el
área metropolitana de monterrey que es
el hogar de unos 5,3 millones de
personas porque porque las autoridades
limitaron drásticamente el acceso al
agua a los residentes en medio de una
extrema sequía mientras que las
embotelladoras comerciales y las
compañías cerveceras de la segunda urbe
más poblada del país sí continuaron
extrayendo miles de millones de galones
de agua por día el presidente ma andrés
manuel lópez obrador decidió tomar
cartas en el asunto
y seguir produciendo
cerveza aumentando la producción todo el
apoyo
[Música]
para al sur-sureste
hay ser grijalva y el usumacinta
ahí está el papaloapan
paulino estamos hablando de poco méxico
pasó de ser el cuarto al principal
exportador de cerveza del mundo en los
últimos 25 años y dentro de los
afectados con la medida estarían
gigantes como heineken o arca
continental que es una de las
embotelladoras de coca-cola más grandes
de américa latina y pues daniela y que
como estamos hablando también con esa
segunda mitad al día hay que respetar
nuestros recursos y pues ir hasta donde
no los permite y pues en esta área que
sucede pues escasez de agua no es lo más
conveniente cuáles son las claves de la
reforma atribución tributaria daniela
planteada por el gobierno colombiano el
recién posicionado presidente gustavo
petro pues raúl va a iniciar entonces el
debate en el congreso de este proyecto
con el que se busca recaudar cerca de 6
mil millones de dólares adicionales en
2023 los fondos serán recaudados
mediante la imposición de más gravámenes
a las personas de altos ingresos así
como a las exportaciones de carbón y de
petróleo pero cuando superen cierto
umbral de precios entre las propuestas
que prometen más polémicas seguramente
estarán los gravámenes que se pretenden
imponer plásticos de un solo uso y
también a las bebidas azucaradas ya los
alimentos ultra procesados dentro de
este grupo le estoy hablando de las
gaseosas los refrescos las golosinas los
embutidos entre otros esta reforma
también persigue impuestos más altos
para ese 2% de la población colombiana
que gana más de 10 millones de pesos
mensuales que equivalen a unos 10
salarios mínimos y también quiere volver
permanente un impuesto sobre el
patrimonio que exceda lo equivalente hoy
a 692.000 dólares también eliminará el
'día sin iva' muy polémico porque dice
que el 'día sin iva' beneficia es a
quienes tienen dinero para comprar
bienes como televisores o computadores
pero no para quienes lo necesitan para
su alimentación básica o sus productos
de la canasta familiar es así daniele y
en ingeniera alta inflación está
provocando problemas a nuestro medio
ambiente pues mire no tienen muchas
alternativas ante este aumento inusitado
de los precios como ocurre en muchos
lugares del mundo pero en este país
específicamente muchos ciudadanos
compran ahora todos los productos de
primera necesidad en cantidades minutos
y también en pequeñas bolsas de plástico
hay quienes creen que están ahorrando sí
pero en el fondo se trata de una mala
estrategia económica que afecta también
al medio ambiente veamos
5 gramos de pasta de dientes o 10
centilitros de aceite de cocina
asfixiados por el coste de la vida los
nigerianos compran ahora todas sus
necesidades básicas en pequeñas
cantidades empaquetadas en minúsculas
bolsas de plástico para consumirlas en
un día café o leche en polvo para una
sola taza unos gramos de cereales para
el desayuno todo se vende ahora en
bolsitas
la situación es muy difícil antes si
alguien quería comprar aceite de
cacahuate me pregunte pero ahora no hay
dinero y las cosas son muy caras
francesas de despensa las marcas detrás
de esta idea la ven como una innovación
que permite el acceso al consumo a todos
los nigerianos la mayoría de los cuales
sobreviven día a día pero para otros es
una aberración económica y ecológica
impacto visual de konami min el impacto
del uso de bolsas en la economía
significa que tenemos más plásticos de
un solo uso que se vierte en el ambiente
a un ritmo muy muy alarmante lo que está
causando mucha preocupación para el
océano las personas y el planeta han
planet la mayor economía de áfrica se ha
visto muy afectada por la en el 19 que
ha hecho subir los precios en cerca del
20% en junio de 2022 frente al mismo mes
del año pasado especialmente los de los
alimentos empujando a otros millones de
nigerianos a la pobreza ahora el país
sufre las consecuencias de la guerra de
ucrania y de una política económica muy
criticada las bolsas pequeñas
aparecieron por primera vez en el
mercado nigeriano a principios de la
década de 2010 con marcas que ofrecían a
los consumidores cantidades reducidas
para animarles a probar nuevos productos
pero en 2016 cuando el país cayó en
recesión por primera vez tras la caída
de los precios del petróleo los usuarios
comenzaron a utilizar este formato en
masa desde entonces la situación
económica no ha mejorado mucho por lo
que la demanda de pequeños envases de
plástico ha seguido disparándose
y cómo están los indicadores económicos
daniela raúl pese en europa las bolsas
operan mixtas con alemania perdiendo más
del 1 por ciento todavía con mucha
incertidumbre sobre el suministro de gas
sobre todo de cara al invierno hoy
precisamente entran en vigencia en
españa las primeras medidas de ahorro
energético que ponen límites al uso del
aire acondicionado en verano y a la
calefacción en invierno y también obliga
a apagar las luces de edificios públicos
que estén desocupados desde las 10 de la
noche en asia las pérdidas las lidera
japonés después de que el fondo de
inversión en tecnología softbank group
reportará una pérdida trimestral récord
está cifra el día el 80% de los bancos
centrales del mundo ya han iniciado
planes para poner en circulación su
propia moneda digital esto según
pricewaterhousecoopers
china es la que más ha avanzado con el
lanzamiento de su joan digital en 2020 y
esto se lo cuento porque el banco
australiano de la reserva anunció que
iniciará un proyecto de un año para
explorar el potencial de tener su propia
moneda digital claro son más seguras que
las alas
se me escapan los nombres ahorita dalila
muchísimas gracias entonces como siempre
por estar con nosotros estas mañanas de
directo américa mañana con más de
economía por supuesto pasamos a saludar
a las mentes con todos los deportes